eine tageskarte ja sehr gut
ja danke für die geschäftsführer andreas
wittwer wäre bereit für die skisaison
aber es fehlt noch der schnee nach der
neun jahre im register plan b das nicht
es ist nicht würdig ag hat dann meine
schwester haben sind vertretbar am
rechten rand
das trampolin interpretierte ein
ponyreiten stadt skifahren im angebot
steht dann ist man wohl in einem
skigebiet unter 2000 meter höhe
in einem gebiet wo sich menschen gegen
das drohende ende des klassischen
wintertourismus stemmen
[Musik]
8 grad plus im berner oberländer die im
total könnte man drei wochen vor
weihnachten noch mountainbiken aber
nicht skifahren
die bergbahnen wir wurden durch lebens
schwierige zeiten nur dank finanzieller
unterstützung der gemeinde und neue
investoren konnte man vor letztes jahr
einen konkurs verhindern
jahr für jahr zurückgegangen und die
letzten fünf jahrzehnte morgen ist es
klingt ist schade dass sie zu trinken
nicht so schlecht ist aber dass sie im
winter trinks 78 einem jahr verbraucht
im schnitt fahren wir gehen eine letzte
schlacht der 34
andreas wittmann ist seit jahren
technischer leiter der wiener hohen
warte
wegen eines abgangs in der
geschäftsleitung hat der letzten fühlen
auch noch die finanzen und das personal
übernommen
derzeit dreht sich fast alles ums wetter
[Musik]
aber jetzt ist frau hat sitzt man sieht
dass sie dabei schnitten etwa wenn wir
schnell
mit einem schnarcher dazu was abgeht das
beschneiden der pisten ist unmöglich im
moment bleibe ihm nichts anderes als
wartungsarbeiten
[Musik]
wichtig ist ein zeugnis geben also zum
beispiel die ganze infrastruktur
dahinter steckt ist das jetzt der winter
ausgerichtet
ja also hier die gebäude um hierhin zu
haben dass sich aber auf wenig reden und
16 uhr verwendet trust gerichtet ja so
macht nämlich zu 100 prozent setzt 18
wir sind die reaktionen auf das telefon
klingelt häufig er muss sich um alles
kümmern
noch ist er entspannt
was stellen mit dem ersten satz von der
kanone nächste woche zuversichtlich
lang zieht wetterprognose sagt ist
nächste woche brachte aber das ist ja
wahnsinn prognose ist englisch wenig
[Musik]
zwei tage vor weihnachten eigentlich war
für heute der saisonstart geplant zwar
hatte man davor während ein paar kalten
tagen beschneiden können
doch dann hat es die piste verregnet
haltungsschäden ja finanziell
eigentliches problem was was bedeutet
dass wir jetzt das land in einer
vierköpfigen familie ist ihres laufes
portmann erschienen
es ist noch hier
das regenwetter
es ist das alles beherrschende thema
sein ding gehört dazu wenn die augen und
brechen
das bedeutet wir sind zweifach oscar
fangen ja ich bin schon da
[Musik]
die bahn ist für viele menschen im 2000
zählen tal wichtig
[Musik]
auch für bauer hans roth wenn im
gegenteil schnee liegt arbeitet der
teilzeit am lift
[Applaus]
die rasch auf dessen boden im tutu
selber und sowieso mit dem konzern
angestellt wurde und ein protour
hausschweine glück sie wurde gefragt ob
ich zum puder auf dauer und finanziell
auf ihnen und sauerstoff wenn du
landwirtschaft noch geschossen
aber dass die gemeinde jetzt bauen
unterstützt
wenn das richtig dass ich dass ich schon
mal gucken was geht es der generation
die heute dass ich nicht nur der traum
und ich zeit aus und bat die erste
partie der aktion gedacht wie möglich
unterstützen
wer sich einmal richtig gut es braucht
wird die letzte finanzhilfe über 150000
franken hat andere gemeindeversammlung
klar angenommen
bei 268 anwesenden gab es lediglich 16
gegenstimmen
[Musik]
bis fast aus
der schulhof mit stilvollen ausrichten
und böse so berühren und ziemlich weit
gehen dass man hier dauerhaft verboten
aber das läuft jetzt
[Musik]
russische reaktion netz inzwischen
schieben oberhelman schnitt das
wanderangebot abschlägen schauen heraus
dass ich ja
[Musik]
die skilifte oben stehen allerdings noch
still
zum leidwesen der pächter des
bergrestaurants schwarzenberg dem
ehepaar martin und andrea burri
[Musik]
naja hier ist natürlich für sechs
matchentscheidend was passiert absitzt
dass die hypo mental zu erfahren schnitt
wird hier nicht modern herbig natürlich
erste priorität ist aus stationen aktiv
mitgewirkt
und das ist auch denen wir der
frankfurter society wcs für das
auszählen der 23 kinder lässt dadurch
ist eine adoptivtochter und ausgerichtet
den ganzen vormittag lassen sich nur
diese beiden blicken
freunde der bier ist im betrieb
mithelfen
[Musik]
andrea bieri und ihr mann haben rund
25000 franken für die sechser investiert
darum hoffen sie so sehr auf schnee
[Musik]
wie wahr
[Applaus]
nix war's der tourenskifahrer von pflegt
sich selber
[Musik]
doch dann ausgerechnet beim mittagessen
endlich die ersten gäste
[Applaus]
euro
immerhin bis am abend werden es 741
franken 50 umsatz sein bis sich die
investitionen decken ist es aber noch
ein weiter weg
[Musik]
nur fünf festangestellte arbeiten bei
den wir die hohen bahn aber lohnt 50
personen sind wie bauer hans rudi weber
im teilzeitpensum angestellt
heute fragt sich wo sie es raus
aber wir sind noch nicht so ganz
gelungen avatare und wie so ein schiff
noch ein stück noten
dazu sollte es ist natürlich schön
aufbereitet und das schnell ersetzt mal
im garten bleiben das später so sehe ich
das
trotz schwierigem beginn der saisonstart
ging doch noch irgendwie über die bühne
es hat in den letzten jahren schlechter
dgg einen monat später
tätigen dorf
es hat viel geschneit
alle lifte laufen
[Musik]
aber es gibt beunruhigende nachricht
geschäftsführer wird mir war eine gute
woche für fast niemanden erreichbar
er musste eine auszeit nehmen hieß es
noch
jetzt
wir fahren mit andreas widmer zum
bergrestaurant schwarzenberg zu den bier
ist er sagt uns er habe alle management
and run den verwaltungsrat abgegeben und
sei nur noch für das technische
verantwortlich
[Musik]
simon der firma kennt informiert als
früher kaum noch niemand eine chance
gerade vor die gegen diese extrem stolz
sie beruf das regelt wie hier
beschäftigt und ich sage es egal ob zwei
meter tiefer und deswegen sehr gut durch
ja absolut
für die machen das sei verständlich
sagte schweer
also mir geht's so sieht der woche geht
ob wir uns nicht
[Musik]
ja
ein höhepunkt der saison das große
familien schieben
[Musik]
der schnee sollte wird ihr wurden bis
saisonende reichen aber es findet ein
umdenken statt
man will in zukunft vermehrt auf
sommertouristen setzen und unabhängige
seien vom winterwetter
was ist hier denn für lehre daraus für
die zukunft was der winter betrifft also
das wussten wir dass die säge party show
ab liebt und das müsse genauso
ausgerechnet source dass das attraktive
partie internet ist im sommer
[Musik]
dass man aber das braucht hat das jahr
zur zeit bis der das wirklich so karte
auf der die zielperson mussawi th
[Musik]
jetzt schon dass napoli gewechselt ist
da seit dem 19 es wächst immer sich
recht ist er fertig machen bilanz ziehen
das nicht so einfach werde das nicht
machen dass eine einmalige übung gewesen
ist
[Musik]